Sí muy buenas noches es un ambiente de
relativa tensión teniendo en cuenta las
respuestas un poco ofensivas como han
descrito ya varios medios nacionales
sobre de los republicanos cuando Donald
cuando Joe biden hacía este discurso de
el estado de la unión muchos le decían a
públicamente es su culpa en cuanto a los
problemas por ejemplo del fentanilo a
los problemas migratorios a los
problemas de armas que el presidente Joe
biden le dijo a los republicanos y a los
demócratas en plenaria que ya era tiempo
de empezar a trabajar de forma conjunta
para encontrar una solución de forma
conjunta y lograr la división la
polarización que se vive en Washington
teniendo en cuenta hoy claramente que
ahora a partir de las elecciones de
medio término pasadas Pues los
republicanos controlan El poder
legislativo la mayoría en la cámara de
representantes y es el partido demócrata
en representación del presidente alguien
que controlan El Ejecutivo esto ha
llevado a una división bastante fuerte
entre republicanos y demócratas entre
los dos partidos y ha llevado Y promete
una parálisis política que precisamente
fue uno de los temas centrales que yo
baiden quiso abordar en este discurso
del estado de la unión es decir trató de
que los republicanos y los demócratas
empezaran a encontrar puntos en común y
los invito por ejemplo a los
republicanos que simplemente no sigan
adelante con su interés de querer
recortar el presupuesto a
la ayuda a adultos mayores el Medicare
que se llama acá a programas sociales
básicos que costó mucho para que Estados
Unidos los financie Y que ahora los
republicanos Pues están dice vayan
tratando de usar para que el como como
herramienta de negociación para que el
techo de la deuda Simplemente no se suba
y no se tengan que seguir financiando
estos programas el presidente fue muy
enfático también en el tema de querer
que las grandes empresas las grandes
corporaciones de Estados Unidos paguen
su tajada justa de impuestos resaltó que
muchas de ellas el año pasado cerca de
50 del año pasado Simplemente no pagaron
impuestos a la renta federal y esto
estos impuestos de pagarlos de dice él
dijo el presidente Joe biden Pues sería
una plata más que suficiente para poder
precisamente no solamente bajar el
déficit tributario sino financiar estos
programas que los republicanos quieren
cortar invitó entonces Y fue ese uno de
los ejes de Los ejes centrales que las
empresas grandes paguen su medida justa
para poder financiar los programas
sociales dijo entre otras cosas que el
capitalismo no es capitalismo si no hay
competencia que si no hay competencia
precisamente el sistema capitalista se
vuelve un sistema de extorsión un
sistema de explotación invitó a las
grandes empresas a dar un paso adelante
y precisamente aportar a esta a esta a
esta a este crecimiento a esta
recuperación económica y sobre todo
recuperación de la clase media que
quiere Joe biden pues empiece a vivirse
de una forma mucho más tajante mucho más
al día a día que muchos estadounidenses
pues no logran ver precisamente porque
los costos de los medicamentos están muy
altos los costos de del mercado está muy
alto Los costos de la energía están muy
altos y entonces precisamente para
enfocarse y darle prioridad a esos temas
nacionales el presidente Joe en este
discurso del estado de la unión su
segundo y su primero teniendo en cuenta
que teniendo en cuenta la mayoría
republicana que se enfrenta en el
legislativo Pues precisamente empezó
este discurso dándole la mano a Kevin
mccarthy nuevo presidente de El Congreso
líder republicano de la de la cámara de
representantes dándole la bienvenida
diciéndole que espera que trabajen
juntos en este y muchos otros temas un
tema económico muy importante que
mencionó el presidente Joe biden fue el
tema de los Microchips estos
dispositivos tecnológicos que todos los
aparatos tecnológicos tienen en su
interior y que les ayudan para su
funcionamiento esta tecnología la creó
Estados Unidos y resaltó que aunque hace
unos años Estados Unidos producía El 40%
de estos dispositivos ahora produce el
10% porque ha tercerizado y Muchos
trabajos estadounidenses han terminado
en Taiwán y en otros lugares Entonces le
pidió a entel a muchas otras empresas
que por favor sigan creciendo estas
fábricas de producción de Microchips no
solamente para asegurar Pues que esa
tecnología se se quede acá en Estados
Unidos y puedan pues eh proveerle a
fabricantes de autos que en su momento
hace unos meses y hace unos años
tuvieron
recorte y tuvieron necesidad de estos
Microchips que no estaban disponibles en
el mercado precisamente porque no se acá
en Estados Unidos y le pidió a estas
empresas que no solamente se produzca
más acá sino que es precisamente fomente
el empleo local al producir estos
Microchips acá en Estados Unidos esto de
cara precisamente a esta tensión con
china porque china Está tratando de
quedarse con esta tecnología para poder
pues ser un jugador importante en ese
mercado de Microchips muchos temas
obviamente a nivel internacional que
trató le dio las gracias por a la
embajadora de Ucrania en Estados Unidos
por estar presente por segunda vez en
en estos discursos del estado de la
unión que ha pronunciado Joe biden y
resaltó que sigue siendo muy importante
que Estados Unidos siga defendiendo la
democracia al seguir dándole armas y
dándole apoyo militar y estratégico a
Ucrania para su defensa contra Rusia y
invitó a los republicanos a muchos
escépticos republicanos que están
cuestionando precisamente esa ayuda a
Ucrania que pues sigan esta importante
labor que avanza Estados Unidos y que
dice yo bailen es importante para
mantener la democracia en Estados Unidos
y en Occidente